foreign
[Music]
Deputy speaker
order let's just make clear from the
beginning this is a very serious
statement on a serious matter that is
affecting a lot of people and the Home
Secretary will be heard
with dignity
Home Secretary thank you madam Dutch
speaker with permission I would like to
make a statement about Asylum processing
at manston and the incident in Dover
yesterday
at around 11 20 a.m on Sunday police
were called to Western jet foil
officers established that two to three
incendiary devices had been thrown at
the home office premises
the suspect was identified
quickly located at a nearby petrol
station
and confirmed dead
the explosive Ordnance disposal unit
attended to ensure there were no further
threats
Kent Police are not currently treating
this as a terrorist incident
fortunately there were only two minor
injuries
but this is a shocking incident
and my thoughts are with all of those
who are affected
speaker I have received regular updates
from the police
while I understand the desire for
answers investigators must have the
necessary space to work
I know the whole house will join me in
paying tribute to everyone involved in
the response including the Emergency
Services military border Force
immigration enforcement and the Asylum
intake unit
Madame W speaker my priority Remains the
safety and the well-being of our teams
and contractors as well as the people in
our care
several hundred migrants were relocated
to manston yesterday to ensure their
safety
Western jet foil is now fully
operational again
I can also inform the house that my
right honorable friend the minister for
immigration visited the manston site
yesterday and that I will visit shortly
my right armor friend was reassured by
the dedication of Staff as they worked
to make this site safe and secure while
suitable onward accommodation is found
as members will be aware
we need to meet our statutory duties
around attention and also fulfill legal
duties to provide accommodation for
those who would otherwise be destitute
we also have a duty to The Wider public
to ensure that anyone who has entered
our country illegally undergoes
essential Security checks and is not
immediately free to wander around local
communities with no fixed abode
when we face so many arrivals so quickly
it is practically impossible to procure
over a thousand beds at such short
notice
consequently we have recently expanded
the site and are working tirelessly to
improve facilities
there are of course competing and heavy
demands on housing stock including for
ukrainians Afghans and social housing
we are negotiating with accommodation
providers
I continue to look at all available
options to overcome the challenges we
face with Supply
this is an urgent matter Madam Deputy
speaker which I will continue to oversee
personally
I will now turn to our immigration and
Asylum system more widely
let me be clear
this is a global migration crisis
we have seen an unprecedented number of
attempts to illegally cross a channel in
small boats
some forty thousand people have crossed
this year alone more than double the
number of arrivals by the same point
last year
not only is it unnecessary because many
have come from another safe country
it is lethally dangerous
we must stop it
it is vital that we dismantle the
international crime gangs behind this
phenomenon
cooperation with the French has stopped
over 29 000 illegal Crossings since the
start of the Year twice as many as last
year and destroyed over a thousand boats
and our UK France joint intelligence
cell has dismantled 55 organized crime
groups since it was established in 2020
the National Crime agency is at the
Forefront of this fight indeed NCAA
officers recently joined what is
believed to be the biggest ever
International operation targeting
smuggling Networks
this year has seen a surge in the number
of Albanian arrivals Madam Deputy
speaker many of them I'm afraid to say
abusing our modern slavery laws
we are working to ensure Albanian cases
are processed and individuals are
removed as swiftly as possible sometimes
within days
the Rwanda partnership will further
disrupt the business model of the
smuggling gangs and deter migrants from
putting their lives at risk
I am committing I'm committed to making
that partnership work labor want to
cancel it
while we will continue to support the
vulnerable fire safe and legal routes
people coming here illegally from safe
countries are not welcome and should not
expect to stay
where it is necessary to change the law
we will not hesitate to do so
I share the sentiment that has been
expressed by members from across the
house who want to see cases in the UK
dealt with swiftly
our Asylum transformation program will
help bring down the backlog it is
already having an impact a pilot in
Leeds reduced interview Times by over a
third and has seen productivity almost
double
we are also determined to address the
wholly unacceptable situation
which has left taxpayers with a bill of
6.8 million pounds a day
for hotel accommodation
and let me set out to the house of
situation that I found when I arrived as
Home Secretary in September at the home
office
I was appalled to learn that there were
over 35
000 migrants staying in hotel
accommodation around the country at
exorbitant cost to the taxpayer
I instigated an urgent review
Home Secretary
I pushed officials to identify
accommodation options which would be
more cost effective and delivered
swiftly while meeting our legal
obligations to migrants
I've held regular operational meetings
with Frontline officials and have been
energetically seeking alternative sites
but I have to be honest this takes time
and there are many hurdles
I foresaw the concerns at manston in
September
and deployed additional resource and
Personnel to deliver a rapid increase in
emergency accommodation
to be clear like the majority of the
British people I am very concerned about
hotels but I've never blocked their
usage indeed since I took over 12 000
people have arrived 9 500 people have
been transferred out of manston or
Western foil many of them into hotels
and I've never ignored legal advice
as a former Attorney General I know the
importance of taking legal advice into
account
at every point
at every point
at every Point Madam Deputy speaker I
have worked hard to find alternative
accommodation to relieve the pressure at
manston
what I have refused to do
is to prematurely release thousands of
people into local communities without
having anywhere for them to stay
that is not just the wrong thing to do
Madam Deputy speaker that would be the
worst thing to do for the local
community in Kent for the safety of
those under our care and for the
Integrity of our borders
the government is Resolute in our
determination to make illegal entry to
the UK unviable
it is unnecessary
lethally dangerous unfair on migrants
who play by the rules and unfair
on the law-abiding patriotic majority of
British people
it is also ruinously expensive and it
makes all of us less safe
Madam Deputy speaker as Home Secretary I
have a plan to bring about the change
that is so urgently needed to deliver an
immigration system that works in the
interests of the British people and I
commend this statement to the house
Shadow whom secretary Yvette Cooper
[Applause]
Madam Deputy speaker and I thank the
Home Secretary for her statement
yesterday's petrol bomb attack on the
western jet fall Center was truly
appalling I'm sure the whole house will
condemn it in the strongest possible
terms and I Echo the home secretary's
tribute to the emergency services and
Border force staff who responded but I
must ask her can't you tell me whether
counter-terror police and
counter-extremism units are involved in
the investigation it doesn't make sense
for them not to be why are they not
turning to the Dreadful conditions at
manston 4 000 people are now on a site
designed to accommodate 1600 people with
some families there for weeks conditions
that have been described as inhumane
with risks of fire disorder and
infection there are confirmed dip Theory
outfit outbreaks reports of Scabies and
MRSA outbreaks also reports of outbreaks
of violence and untrained staff she said
nothing about what she was doing to
address those immediate Public Health
crises and also the issues for untrained
staff Behind These are deeper failures
in the government's policies on Asylum
and channel Crossings decision making
has collapsed the home office took just
14 000 initial Asylum decisions in the
last 12 months compared to 28 000 six
years ago 96 of the small boat arrivals
last year have still not had a decision
and initial decisions alone are taking
more than 400 Days on this conservative
government's watch can she confirm that
the nationality's borders Bill and
changes to immigration rules have in
fact added further bureaucracy and
delays leading to tens of thousands more
people waiting in Asylum accommodation
and more than a hundred million pounds
extra on Asylum accommodation bills
because their policies are pushing up
the use of hotels and the increase in
delays there's also been a total failure
to protect to prevent a huge
proliferation of gangs in the channel
why has the Home Secretary refused our
calls for a major New National Crime
agency unit with hundreds of additional
specialist officers to work with europol
and others to crack down on the gangs as
well as the Urgent work needed with
France to get a proper agreement in
place and can she also confirm on the
Rwanda plan that she has spent an extra
20 million pounds on top of the hundred
and 120 million pounds already spent on
a policy that she has herself described
as failing and that her officials have
described as unenforceable and with a
high risk of Fraud and isn't it now time
to drop this unethical and unworkable
scheme and put the money into tackling
the backlogs and tackling the criminal
gangs instead and let me ask her about
her own decisions which are very they're
a very serious allegations now being
reported that the Home Secretary was
warned by officials and other ministers
she was acting outside the law by
failing to provide alternative
accommodation
can she confirm that she turned down
plans contingency plans that she was
offered that would have reduced
overcrowding as the reports say there
are also legal obligations including
under the 1999 Act and the 2018
regulations can she confirm she was
advised repeatedly that she was breaking
the law by failing to agree to these
plans one of these meetings on manston
was on the 19th of October can she
confirm she refused these proposals on
that date it was the same day that she
broke sections 2.3 and sections 1.4 of
the ministerial code so can she confirm
or can she tell us whether in fact she
breached the ministerial code which
provides for ministers abiding by the
law did she breach the ministerial code
three times in a single day and how is
anyone supposed to have confidence in
her as a Home Secretary with these
serious issues she referred in her
statement to Security checks these are
very important but her statement his
disregard is undermined by her own
disregard for security her letter today
says makes clear that the incident over
which she resigned was not a one-off and
rather and contrary to her previous
claims to have reported the breach
rapidly as soon as she realized she
instead had to be challenged several
times by one of her colleagues she has
also not answered the crucial questions
about security breaches while she was
attorney general can she tell us whether
she was involved in a leap to the
telegraph reported in the telegraph on
the 21st of January about information
about attorney general action on a case
involving the security service has she
sent any other government documents by
WhatsApp telegram or other social media
and given that it's been less than a
week since she was reappointed and less
than a fortnight since she was first
forced to resign for breaching the
ministerial code and every day since her
appointment there have been more stories
about possible security or ministerial
code breaches how is anybody supposed to
have confidence in her given the serious
responsibilities of the Home Secretary
to stand up for our national security
for security standards and for Public
Safety the Prime Minister promised that
this would be a government of Integrity
of professionalism and of accountability
isn't the Home Secretary letting
everyone down and failing on all of
these countries
here
thank you madam Mr Speaker to pick up on
some of the specific points that the
vulnerable lady mentions I'm not going
to comment on any details relating to
this specific case or the individual uh
under consideration but there has been
clear work uh afoot with the NCA and all
Partners to try and tackle the problem
of illegal migration I'm very encouraged
by the relationship that we have built
with the French and I'm grateful to the
French authorities for their real
commitment and work on tackling this
problem but it's absolutely clear that
as I made clear in my statement that on
no occasion did I block hotels or veto
advice to procure extra and emergency
accommodation actually the the data and
the facts are that on my watch since the
6th of September over 30 new hotels were
agreed which would provide over 4 500
additional Hotel tell bed spaces which
will be brought into use since the start
of October over 13 new hotels will
provide over 1800 additional Hotel bed
spaces so and also since the 6th of
September 9 000 migrants have left
manston uh many of them heading towards
Hotel accommodation those are the facts
I encourage the right from the lady to
stick to the facts and not fantasy
Madame Baptist speaker however she
raises some other points and I would
just like to say this that my letter to
the home Affairs select committee sent
today addresses all of the matters that
she has just raised transparently and
comprehensively I've been clear that I
made an error of judgment I apologized
for that error I took responsibility for
it and I resigned
so Madame Deputy sneaker
does the hugs want to hear what the Home
Secretary has to say
Home Secretary
I apologize for the era I took
responsibility Madam Deputy speaker and
I resigned for the era
but let's be clear about what's really
going on here Madam speaker
the British people deserve to know which
party is serious about stopping The
Invasion on our Southern post and which
party is not some 40
000 people have arrived on the south
coast this year alone many of them
facilitated by criminal gangs some of
them actual members of criminal gangs so
let's stop pretending that they are all
refugees in distress the whole country
knows that that is not true and It's
Only The Honorable members opposite who
pretend otherwise Madam Deputy speaker
we need to be straight with the public
the system is broken illegal
migration
[Applause]
illegal migration is out of control and
too many people are more interested in
playing political parlor games
covering up the truth then solving the
problem
I Madam Deputy speaker I'm utterly
serious about ending the scourge of
illegal migration and I am determined to
do whatever it takes to break the
criminal gangs and fix our hopelessly
lacks Asylum system that Madame Deputy
speaker is why I am in government
and that is why there are some people
who would prefer to be rid of me
well
[Applause]
but order
I should just point out that I can hear
who's making the noise and it'll be a
long time before they're called to ask a
question it's actually a steak
Madam Deputy speaker let them try
I know that I speak for the decent law
abiding patriotic majority
British people 's people from every
background that wants safe and secure
borders labor is Running Scared that
this party might just deliver them
[Applause]
sir Roger Gail
The Madam Deputy speaker will you allow
me first to express my condolences to
the family of families of those affected
by the incidents of Dover and
particularly the family of the man who
was responsible who had very severe
mental health difficulties I think our
thoughts ought to be with all of them
Madam Deputy speaker can I also thank my
right-honorable friend the minister of
State
for taking the trouble and the time to
come yesterday to see the facilities at
manston foot himself and to greatly
understand the problems that we've been
facing and can I thank the staff at
Manson for the incredible Dedication
that they've been showing under very
difficult circumstances they are doing a
superb job and I hope everybody
understands that
Madam Deputy speaker the facility at
manston's the the Asylum processing
facility was opened in January
to take 1500 people and to process them
daily in a lot more than 24 more than 48
hours but mainly in 24 hours that
facility operated absolutely
magnificently and very efficiently
indeed until five weeks ago
when I'm afraid
the Home Secretary took the policy
decision not to commission further
accommodation
and it is that that has led to the
crisis at manston
will my right honorable friend the Home
Secretary now give the house an
assurance
first that the adequate accommodation
will be provided to enable the manston
facility to return to its previous work
will she honor the undertaking given by
the right honorable lady the member for
Witham and my honorable friend the
member for Corby who have indicated that
this would be a temporary facility
handling only 1500 people
per day and that it would not be a
permanent residence and will she give a
further undertaking that under no
circumstances will manston be turned
into a permanent refugee camp yeah
well I thank my honorable friend for his
uh commitment to safeguarding the people
who are at manston and representing his
local constituents uh in the area and I
was very pleased to meet with him a few
weeks ago to hear uh from him about the
situation at manston as I said uh I just
must gently correct him however on no
occasion have I blocked the procurement
of hotels or alternative accommodation
to ease the pressure on manston I'm
afraid that simply isn't true and I I
since I'll repeat it again but since
September the 6th when I was appointed
over 30 new hotels have been agreed to
they would provide over 4 500 additional
Hotel bed spaces many of those available
to the people in manston also since the
6th of September over 9 000 people have
left manston many of those heading
towards hotels so on no occasion have I
blocked the use of hotels and I would
just gently refer members of the House
who seem to be laboring under that
apprehension to the home Affairs select
committee session last week where
officials
um and the various front line uh
professionals who've been working with
me on this issue confirm that we've been
working energetically to procure
alternative accommodation
urgently for several weeks now there are
procedural and resource
difficulties and challenges in doing
that quickly I would very much like to
get alternative accommodation delivered
more quickly but we are working at PACE
to deliver contingency accommodation to
a deal with this acute problem
Stuart McDonald
thank you very much Madame Deputy
speaker I thank the Home Secretary for
her statement and I joined the whole
house in condemning the frightening
attack at Western jet foil and sending
our sympathy to all those who are
impacted and indeed our thanks to all
who responded so professionally but
Madam speaker responsibility for the
disaster and dysfunction at manston and
the unlawful detention conditions there
lies squarely with the Home Secretary
herself and her predecessors she and
they knew what was happening including
the numbers arriving and she was
provided with advice that by all
accounts she did not act on now she's
very carefully said that she did not
block hotel use but did she at any point
avoid supporting new procurement and if
not why is it that we heard that her
successor or predecessor depending on
which way you look at it had to
intervene ultimately Madam speaker what
was a functioning facility in the summer
is now totally unsafe and that was on
her watch
looking to the Future what now
unfortunately the Home Secretary offers
only the same old failed sound bites
discredited policies and nasty rhetoric
what we need is an expansion of safe
legal Roots at a minimum reversing the
loss of the routes under the Dublin
convention instead of 120 million pounds
in a disgraceful Rwanda dream that could
have traveled the number of Asylum
caseworkers working to clear the backlog
and why not fast track fast forward
claims for example from the 16 000
syrians and Afghans half of whom have
been waiting for over six months make
decisions on their cases quickly 95 and
more will get Asylum they can move on
and we can free up accommodation
and a speaker on her letter today last
week the home sector resigned claiming
she accepted responsibility but the
facts suggests that she tried to dodge
it but got caught why else did she find
time to request The Accidental email
recipient was to delete and forget he
only notified senior officials in the
Prime Minister after being confronted
these excuses will not wash ultimately
how can one so-called misjudgment last
week be a resignation offense and yet
she can stay this week after admitting
six of the very same misjudgments she
said no documents were top secret but
how many were marked official and
sensitive did you do similar as attorney
general how do we know
so quickly after an admitted the
ministerial could reach as a farce it
reflects poorly on her and poorly on the
Prime Minister both should think again
so that someone else can get on with the
real work
thank you madam speaker I refer The
Honorable gentleman to the letter that I
sent today to the chairman of the home
Affairs select committee I've been
upfront about the details of my diary on
the 19th of October
Cooperative with any review that's taken
place I've apologized I've taken
responsibility and that's why I resigned
I hope the house will see that I'm
willing to apologize without hesitation
for what I've done and any mistakes that
I've made but what I will not do under
any circumstances is apologize for
things that I haven't done
it's been said that I sent a top secret
document that's wrong
it's been said that I sent a document
about cyber security what's wrong it's
been said that I sent a document about
the intelligence agencies that would
compromise National Security and it's
wrong wrong Madam Deputy speaker what is
wrong is that I'm worrying is that
without compunction these assertions
have been
repeated as facts by politicians and
journalists
and I'm grateful to have had the
opportunity to clarify the record today
Natalie elfing
okay Madam Deputy speaker and I'd like
to put on record my thanks to all of the
First Responders to the horrific uh
incidents that happened at Dover
yesterday
constituents working at the Dover
Facility have raised concerns about the
current safety at the site does my right
honorable friend agree with me that this
type of facility has no place in a busy
open port like Dover and could you look
at moving it to a more appropriate
secure location immediately and does she
also agree that we cannot keep doing
more of the same paying millions of
pounds to the French but seeing ever
increasing numbers of illegal arrivals
now time for a new approach for the
French to stop the boats leaving the
French beaches a joint channel security
Zone to tackle this issue and bringing
out this illegal immigration activity
once and for all
I want you to thank my honorable friend
for her indefatigable campaigning on
this issue and and I've been very
grateful to her for her direct input on
this issue this is incredibly difficult
I don't want to uh you know sugarcoat
the problem there are incredibly
multifaceted challenges that we have to
deal with and when it comes to manston
like her I'm very concerned about the
conditions and I have been so for
several weeks that's why I've taken
urgent action to stand up an operational
team to put put to increase the
emergency accommodation on the site on a
temporary and emergency basis I was not
willing to release hundreds of migrants
into the local community I I won't do
that and you know I will do everything I
can to find cost-effective and practical
Alternatives we need to find many more
uh sites for accommodation and beds we
are looking at all instances where
whether that is hotels whether that's
land owned by other agencies for example
mod or other government departments
looking at other dispersal around the
country we have to look exhaustively but
it isn't easy
Johnson
can I welcome the Home Secretary to her
place and I look forward to her
attending at the home Affairs select
committee on the 23rd of November as we
haven't seen a Home Secretary since
February of this year outrage the whole
Affairs select committee heard evidence
last week that manston was at breaking
point we were also told by the Home
office's director general for customer
services that three hotels were approved
one week ago when the right honorable
member for well in Hatfield was the then
Home Secretary so can we hope this Home
Secretary confirm exactly how many
hotels or alternative accommodation
options she was personally invited by
her officials to approve for use during
her first tenure as Home Secretary and
how many hotels or alternative
accommodation options she actually did
Grant approval and permission for during
her time and finally perhaps um the Home
Secretary might wish to join the home
Affairs select committee when we visit
manston again for the second time this
week
well I was I read with interest the
session that The Honorable lady
conducted last week at her select
committee and I was I was one up on
record my immense thanks to the
officials uh the officials that you had
evidence for from are brilliant and
simply the best in the business and they
work day in day out to try and get the
best service and I note from questions
67 to 78 approximately you know there
was a lot of discussion about my
involvement and my grip of the situation
and I'm I encourage all members to read
that section of the transcript which
confirms on the record by officials with
whom I've been working directly that
there has been active uh procurement for
of hotels there's been a huge amount of
work which has been put on how many I
will repeat myself again since the 6th
of September over 30 new hotels have
been agreed providing over 4
500 additional Hotel bed spaces that's
has been under my watch that's been when
I've been in charge of the home office
and I'm very grateful to all those
officials I must put on record my thanks
to uh The Departed now departed Minister
purse glove who's been instrumental in
assisting in dealing with this problem
Craig McKinley
okay uh my bright honorable friend
mentioned albanians in her her statement
I hear that two-thirds of those at
menston are albanians does she have an
absolute figure for that but is my right
honorable friend aware that in Germany
and Sweden that works at the same
immigration records as we do they allow
zero applicants from Albania surely it
stands to reason that an EU applicant
country a NATO country a country that's
in the Council of Europe and is patently
not a war zone we should not be
accepting Refugee status and claims from
such a country what is she going to do
about that aspect of this problem
well my honorable friend again raiser a
very important feature which has emerged
over the last
six to nine months about the prominence
of uh Albanian migrants arriving on our
Shores and he's right Albania is not a
war-torn country and it is uh very uh
difficult to see how claims for Asylum
really can be legitimate claims for a
sign and I would also note that we see a
large number of Albanian migrants
arriving here and claiming to be victims
of modern slavery again I really am
circumspect of those claims because
Albania of course is a signatory to the
European convention against trafficking
the original convention that underlies
our modern slavery laws and actually if
those people are genuinely modern
slavery victims they should be claiming
that protection in Albania
yeah
Diane Albert
see the Home Secretary will be aware
that one of the problems with the Asylum
system is the unacceptably long time it
takes to process claims
first Select Community of evidence from
the Independent Chief Inspector of bulls
immigration and he told us that
currently
caseworkers decision makers are making
1.3 decisions a week
the Leeds pilot which is referred to
has put the numbers of decisions up to
2.7 decisions a week
doesn't the home sector understand that
this is far too slow what is she going
to do about it and isn't it the case
that if she spent less time playing to
the gallery on immigration and more time
dealing with the Practical problems this
would be to the benefit of a taxpayer
the home office staff that works so hard
and to the Asylum Seekers themselves
yeah
it's not often I say this Madam literacy
but I do actually agree with a lot of
what the right honorable ladies just
said she is right and when I've arrived
when I arrived at the home office in
September I was very dismayed to find
that as was set out at the select
committee last week only four percent of
uh those claims waiting in the system
have been processed so far so we have a
very slow moving system that is
unacceptable and that is a big part of
the problem and part of our plan to
solve the problem is to speed up Asylum
processing we're putting more resources
behind it we're putting more technology
behind it we're trying to identify how
we can be more efficient but yes it's a
big feature which is clogging up the
system and we see the pressure bearing
uh you know playing out at manston
Tim Lawson figure clearly the situation
that Manson's become unsustainable
because of the record numbers coming
across the channel 40 000 and November
last year was the highest month so we
haven't seen the end of it and of course
as my honorable friend from uh Planet
South has said a record number of
albanians 12 000 up from just fifty two
years ago so following on for his
question what exactly is the arrangement
with the Albanian the government about
Returns what Arrangements is she looking
at to fast-track albanians potentially
in separate processing centers helped by
those Albanian officials we've allowed
to come here to assist how many
albanians have so far been returned in
the last 12 months how many of those
albanians have taken voluntary return
payments to return and of those how many
of them have actually come back to the
UK again
well again you're uh The Honorable my
right Animal Friend Is Right to mention
the returns agreement and what that we
really want to maximize the uh
deployment of the terms of that
agreement I think that's a brilliant
starting point for trying to accelerate
some of the processing and ultimately
the removals of Albanian Nationals
Albanian Nationals are received in the
same way as other small boat arrivals
and however due to the excellent
relationship build with my Albanian
counterpart we are able to expedite
removal of albanians who have no reason
to be in the UK we want to maximize that
we want to push forward the back and
faster
Aleister Carmichael thank you madam
Deputy speaker I'd like to read to the
homesick for a text message that a
colleague of mine received this
afternoon from an immigration expert
you say it's just had a call with
Ukraine that has reduced our team to
tears
people are facing losing their lives in
Kiev or watching their children freeze
in the countryside purely because of
delays in processing their visas you UK
home office people pushing and
unnecessary weights are costing people
their lives in Ukraine
Ukraine modern Deputy speaker not
Albania Ukraine is that what the Home
Secretary means when she says that this
is a government taking Asylum seriously
secretary well I I do dispute his his
version of events with respect since
2015. Amanda speaker the UK has offered
a place to over 380
000 men women and children seeking
safety including those from Hong Kong
Syria Afghanistan and Ukraine as well as
many family members of refugees
John radwood I strongly support all that
the Home Secretary said in her opening
statement she spoke for the nation in
saying we need to control this problem
and she spoke for all those caught up in
in these tragic events so I hope that
all men and women of good will get
behind her and that the home office will
fully support her in making sure we can
speed up processing and in returning all
those illegal economic migrants to the
safe countries they came from
secretary my right order a friend speaks
a lot of sense as always and he's right
the British people have had enough of an
out-of-control borders system and it's
incumbent on this government and I know
for a fact that this prime minister
takes this issue extremely seriously and
I know that he will leave no stone
unturned until the problem is fixed
thank you madam Deputy speaker
there is nothing patriotic about making
children suffer but that is exactly what
is happening as a direct result of this
home secretary's failure to get to grips
with processing Asylum she talks at the
hotels are somehow a better option in my
constituency there is one with a hundred
and fifty children in squeezed alongside
another 350 adults seven or eights to a
room no notice to the local Authority
they would be placed there no cooking
facilities no school places for these
primary school age children no clothes
for most of them especially for the
winter weather no play facilities if
they are allowed out at all of these
prisons no safeguarding as far as any of
us can see
if the Home Secretary is so confident
that this is meeting her duty of Care on
behalf of this country then will she
publish the contract requirements for
how children are housed in hotels and
the precise details the sorts of
services they should expect and that we
should be proud of as a country dealing
with those fleeing Asylum
secretary
well we are currently uh accommodating
um unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
in hotels
um with a Mac with hotels with a maximum
occupancy of 353 and there is additional
accommodation available uh coming on
stream but what I would just say to The
Honorable lady is this I think it's a
fallacy to suggest that we're somehow
cutting Corners when I've arrived at the
home office I've been frankly very
dismayed and appalled to find that we're
spending on average 150 pounds per
person per night to accommodate people
in hotels by my standard that's quite a
nice hotel and upon my review and closer
scrutiny of how that decision making was
taking place I identified several
four-star hotels around the country
being procured for this purpose for me
that's not an acceptable use of
taxpayers money
Jane hunt
oh thank you very much Madam Dr speaker
unsolicited economic migration to the UK
via illegal trafficking Must Be Stopped
we must use our limited resources to
support valid Asylum cases that have not
come from a safe country what steps is
the home office taking to return illegal
immigrants now to their home countries
in the cases of countries who will
accept them
[Music]
them secretary well
um we take removals very importantly and
actually part of the plan to solve this
is actually to try and accelerate the
turnaround and the processing of people
who are arriving illegally we've had
some success recently in removing people
back to Albania within quite a short
period of time but we need to go further
and faster
Joanna Cherry thank you madam Deputy
speaker can I just gently remind the
Home Secretary that it is not illegal to
seek Asylum what is what is illegal is
to detain people without a proper basis
and law yeah yeah so can she confirm
that she has ignored legal advice that
keeping these Asylum Seekers at manston
for more than 25 four hours could be
illegal detention can she also tell us
whether she's been advised that what's
happening at manston May amount to
unlawful deprivation of Liberty in terms
of Article 5 of the echr and also
inhuman and degrading treatment in terms
of article 3 echr now despite the home
secretary's best efforts we're still
bound to uh to comply with the
convention by virtue of our domestic law
so what's she going to do about all of
this and even if she doesn't care about
the human rights of the people detained
at manston does she understand that her
failure to obey the law here may end up
costing the taxpayers vast amounts of
money in terms of court fees and damages
yeah
well I confirm that I have not and ever
ignored legal advice the law offices
convention probably still take very
seriously means I won't comment on the
contents of legal advice that I may have
seen But what I will say is this I am
not prepared to release migrants
prematurely into the local community in
Kent to no fixed Abode that's an
unacceptable option to me
Nick Fletcher
[Applause]
[Music]
in the Secretary of statement she spoke
with the successes of the UK French
joint Alliance style stopping 29 000
illegal immigrants across him what are
their thoughts on doubling these
resources and finally eliminating these
dangerous Crossings
tackle this issue is about increasing
our resources and our manpower to
intercept and detect the organized
criminal gangs Upstream that's what part
of the work with the French entails and
that's why I was very encouraged by
discussions I've had with my French
counterpart Minister damama about how we
can work better and more closely
together with our intelligence agencies
and our law enforcement agencies uh
jointly uh Upstream to try and intercept
early on
Ben Bradshaw thank you madam Deputy
speaker is it still explained to
incoming ministers as it was to me more
than 21 years ago how easily one's
mobile phone can be compromised by
organized criminals and hostile foreign
powers if so how was her mobile phone
and the mobile phone of the former prime
minister the member for Southwest
Norfolk compromised in these security
breaches
I'm secretary
well I've set out the details in the
letter of today but my I've made it
clear that there was no issue about a
compromise to National Security
so there's one swing can I thank her for
her dedication and the work that she is
doing what are the prospects of securing
an alternative Airline carrier to make
the Rwanda plan a reality
secretary I'm I'm very
uh the right honorable my horrible
friend of the member for Witham and the
the former prime minister the member I
remember Uxbridge and I think that it is
uh incredibly uh crucial to our
multi-faceted approach to this problem
if you look at the Australian experience
of tackling a similar issue they will
say that one very powerful tool they had
in tacking the problem was the moment
they were able to return people or move
them out of the territory to Papua New
Guinea or nauru had a massive deterrent
effect and that's what we want to deploy
Rachel maskel thank you madam Deputy
speaker the conditions are manston are
clearly unsafe and
inhumane and we know obviously the
suffering that people have experienced
there after 12 years of shameful uh
watch of of this government however we
also do understand the lack of
accommodation across the country and
that's why I asked the Home Secretary
why she won't open up a homes to a
refugee scheme so people in our
communities can support people properly
within our own communities
Home Secretary whilst the issue at
Madison is
on on
indisputably concerning I don't want us
to create alarm unnecessarily so when
she talks about uh the language that she
uses I do I do gently urge her not not
to use inflammatory language we are
aware for example for example we are
aware of a very small number of cases of
diphtheria reported at manston but there
are very good medical facilities there
all protocols have been followed people
are being fed they are being clothed
they are being sheltered there are very
high numbers at Manson unprecedented
numbers we are working at PACE to
alleviate that pressure and getting
people out we anticipate hopefully 300
people leaving this evening and so on
throughout the week we are working
urgently to solve the problem
Dr Julian Lewis Madam Deputy speaker
given that it seems virtually impossible
to stop large numbers of people Landing
illegally
does she think it will be possible to
enable those who have landed illegally
and have a poor case to be removed
promptly without a change in the law and
if she thinks the law has to be changed
which law is it
I'm secretary well one of the other
plans that we've been working on is to
change the law because unfortunately our
laws have too low a threshold and that's
why our modern slavery laws are being
abused by uh you know illegitimate
claimants and we also need to take
action to it to accelerate the process
and to prevent the um the the the
exploitation of our laws people are
coming here they're claiming Asylum
unfairly uh
unjustifiably they're claiming modern
slavery laws they're abusing our human
rights laws and our other protections
they're frankly taking advantage of the
generosity of the British people
thank you madam Deputy speaker manston
is supposed to be a short-term holding
facility people are not supposed to be
there for more than 48 hours that means
people must be being detained illegally
in these conditions so will the Home
Secretary tell us how many people have
been detained for more than 48 hours how
many claims for unlawful detention is
she expecting and at what cost
Home Secretary well we are aware that
people have been uh detained and we have
very very high numbers at Manson and
that's why we're taking really
exhaustive steps to ensure that we can
alternative sites we're looking at the
dispersal mechanism and and sites around
the country and other local authorities
we are looking at hotels unfortunately
we have no other choice but to look at
hotels at the moment we are looking at
other immigration detention or removal
centers so we're looking at a wide range
of alternative places to which we can
safely accommodate the migrants
speaker
can I welcome the home secretary's uh
statement uh in it she says importantly
that everybody who arrives illegally
undergoes essential Security checks
before their release could she confirm
that this applies not just to those who
claim Asylum but also those who land do
not claim Asylum and are in effect
arriving without a Visa and therefore
are eligible for temporary release from
which they may not return
circuitry
well well he's right that the processing
is as follows people will arrive they go
first of all to Western the Western jet
foil where they are
um you know they get dry clothes they
are looked after in the immediate
arrival uh onto the territory they are
then taken to manston uh for biosecurity
and Security checks is the uh the type
that he's just talked about
it's Brian thank you Mr Deputy speaker
she says the system's broken well yes it
is broken when you see the number of
people taking dangerous trips across the
channel rise year on year and Year yes
it's broken when it takes longer and
longer to deal with individual claims so
it's of Greater cost to the British
taxpayer yes it's broken when you have
thousands of people in completely
inappropriate accommodation which is
probably breaking the law and they may
end up having to seek compensation
against the government again threatening
the taxpayer yes it's broken when
ministers a Home Secretary breaches the
ministerial code six times and only
thinks that she has to step aside for
six days I believe in the rehabilitation
of offenders but don't you have to serve
the time first or is there one rule for
everybody else in a completely different
one for her
uh well I I generally refer The
Honorable gentleman to my letter that I
sent today to the chairman of the home
Affairs committee that's been clear
about timeline the my actions the
decisions for my actions I apologized I
took responsibility and that's why I
resigned but what this political Witch
Hunt is all about is about ignoring the
facts of the problem the facts of the
problem are that we are we do have a
problem with the slow time that it takes
to process Asylum claims and that's why
we are taking immediate action to bring
the Asylum backlog down we've got a a
pilot which is being rolled out we've
got more uh resources and decision
makers being put into the front line and
we've got a different system of trying
to assess the claims that we can try and
speed up the time that people are
waiting for a decision
it's William cash may I commend my right
normal friends very strongly for her
statement
um does she agree that we must make a
clear legal and enforceable distinction
in statute law between genuine refugees
and illegal economic migrants and deal
with this problem once and for all
and secretary well my honorable friend
is spot on I think we have to
tell the truth to the British people
this is not the not you know these
people are not all refugees fleeing War
fleeing persecution with human rights
violations that they have suffered they
are coming here often at their own will
often having paid tens of thousands of
pounds to have procured a dangerous and
lethal Journey illegally across the
channel because they know that our laws
aren't fit for purpose and they know
that they can get away with a spurious
claim Alison thulis thank you very much
reported that children are being
detained at the Manson State can she
confirm because her Minister couldn't
confirm last week how many children are
on site right now here secretary
well we don't routinely detain children
or unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
at manston but there are a number of
unaccompanied Asylum sites seeing
children have been accommodated not
detained for a brief period this summer
while the accommodation was identified
and of course people were evacuated to
Manson yesterday and that did include
children so Edward Lee
if people don't want to go to Manson
they can stay in France
but we all know what's really Behind
These unpleasant personal attacks is
because this home sector is the only one
with the guts the determination is the
legal knowledge to reform our ridiculous
human rights law entertain these people
which is the only way and send them back
the only way that we're going to deal
with this and those who constantly make
these personal attacks to somebody who
has made just one mistake and apologize
to remember the old motto remember the
old motto understand and judge not has
she the determination to amend our
ridiculous laws
secretary my friend is absolutely right
we need to change the law there are too
many people here coming here and and
making spurious human rights claims
protracting the Asylum application
system they know that they can put in
appeal after appeal they can challenge
decisions and they can spend a lot of
time I'm here in full knowledge of the
fact that they are not genuine Asylum
Seekers
thank you Mr Deputy speaker as the home
Affairs collect committee report showed
it's a process unaccompanied children
the report also Illustrated that some of
these unaccompanied children go missing
from their hotels sometimes temporarily
and sometimes permanently what is the
Home Secretary doing to find these
children and to protect them from
criminal or sexual exploitation
well of course it's very serious when a
child goes missing and particularly in
those circumstances and when that does
happen we work very closely with the
local authorities and the police to
operate a robust missing persons
protocol we've also changed the national
transfer scheme so all local authorities
for children's services must support
young people and we need to identify and
ensure that proper risk assessments are
put in place so that we can properly put
in place the the proper protections to
make sure this doesn't happen growing
Oaks
can I declare my interest as a member of
the ramp project can I ask my wife and
my friend the Home Secretary returning
to the issue of children we've seen some
terrible accounts of children sleeping
on mats at manston can she reassure the
house that no children are being kept at
manston for longer than 48 hours that
they're a proper safeguarding procedures
in place can she let us know what work
is being done with Kent County Council
to make sure that those children that
are there are being safeguarded and can
she please urge her right on my right
honorable friend the immigration
minister to come to the women in
equality select committee where we're
doing an inquiry into the Asylum system
he's not available this Wednesday but
can he make it as soon as possible
please
I'm sorry well we take extremely
seriously our duty towards a duty of
care towards children and young people
who are in the system and and and as I
said there are delays in the system
because of an extortionate amount of
cases which are due to be processed but
we need we are working to prioritize
applications from children and young
people where possible and we want to
increase overall decision making uh and
the numbers and the capacity so that
children are processed far more quickly
than others for eagle
very much Mr Deputy speaker the Home
Secretary has come to the house today
and announced to us that the immigration
system is broken
can she tell us who's been in power for
the last 12 years
so great
well I'll tell you what the British
people need to know they need to know
that it was the labor government who
oversaw Mass migration and effectively a
de facto open borders policy with record
levels of immigration into this country
and as the labor party that will
continue to allow our uncontrolled
borders they would cancel Rwanda they
would not take any action to stop
illegal migration and they would make a
mockery of our borders Kate knife done
thank you Mr Deputy speaker the
secretary of state will be aware of
concerns that I've raised recently about
the lack of joined up planning between
the home office serco and local
authorities regarding Asylum
accommodation and the specific concerns
I've raised regarding the issue of the
use of a hotel in my constituency of
Burton can I there for us the Secretary
of State to meet with me and the
Staffordshire leaders board who are Keen
to ensure a joined up approach to Asylum
dispersal through improved community
education between local authorities
serco and the home office so great
well coming into the home office in
September has really shown me how the
decision-making process behind choosing
the hotels goes on and I've heard from
several colleagues about their concerns
about the use of hotels I'm very happy
to meet with her and her colleagues to
to hear about the concerns in her local
area that you know we need to make them
much more evenly distributed we need to
make sure that areas are taking their
fair share and But ultimately we need to
ensure that people have a bed to stay in
and a room to stay in because that is
where the problem originates please
remain seated to answer ask your
question Alan Alan Durants
all right
thank you Mr Speaker good evening Mr
Deputy speaker I'm sure that all members
of this house will join me in thanking
the staff undertaking a difficult task
of keeping everyone safe in these
challenging circumstances Mr Speaker
well I hope the secretary give firm
assurances today that members of the
prison Officers Association and other
staff working at manston will remain
free from personal liability for any
illegal Decisions by the government
around extended detention secretary
well we are always concerned about the
personal responsibility and safety of
the staff at Manson and let me just take
this opportunity to pay tribute to every
single person who's been working on the
front line in particular over the last
few days where it's been quite chronic
quite acute and incredibly tough uh for
them so they'll be they are doing a
brilliant job and will do everything to
ensure that their professional positions
are safeguarded
we need to change the definition of
asylum many people who are in these
centers and hotels are illegal migrants
many of them have taken the chance their
economic migrants who are taking a
chance by crossing the English Channel
can I ask the Home Secretary if people
come here illegally why can't we just
Deport them
well he raises an important point and
he's absolutely right if you look at
other European countries they take a
very different approach to the
consideration and processing of Asylum
claims the reality is is once someone
makes an asylum claim we are Duty bound
to consider it uh what the Rwanda scheme
does and what's very good about that is
it means that the Asylum claim will be
considered in Rwanda and therefore we
will be able to physically remove them
before that long time delay takes place
Joe McDonald
I have I have had consistently
um 1500 Asylum seekers in hotels in my
constituency I think it's the largest
number in any constituency and I welcome
them I welcome them and I congratulate
the local agencies the local voluntary
sector local churches goodwires and
mosque but all the support that they've
given to these people because of the
experiences that they've gone through
many of them suffer from post-traumatic
stress disorder
however this situation was meant to be
resolved by relocation and the fast
processing of the cases themselves the
bulk of which I believe are accepted
when they are processed or accepted as
genuine Asylum Seekers
that means that now we're into our
second year and Beyond
um it means there is a need now to
review the resources that is going into
local areas like mine a ticket to
support the local NHS and local schools
and yes the local Authority and local
voluntary sector can I ask the Home
Secretary to initiate that review as
rapidly as possible we want to do all we
can to assist these people but obviously
we need the local resources to do that
well there are challenges as I've set
out today in securing sufficient
accommodation full stop whether that's
hotels or dispersal accommodation and
that's due to the limited private rental
market stock we do work with local
authorities to ensure that there's
sufficient support for people who are
arriving in those areas but yes there is
a definite pressure uh financial and
otherwise by people being accommodated
for long periods of time around the
country
Lee Anderson
speaker now that we've got Albanian
criminals leaving Albania which is a
safe country the same criminals then
setting up shop in France
they then leave in France which is a
safe country and coming to the UK across
the channel
and then when you get this accommodation
we've got the opposition parties saying
the accommodation is not good enough for
them yeah well does the Home Secretary
agree with me that the accommodation is
not good enough for them they can get on
a dinghy and go straight back to France
take a break well my friend's right the
average
cost per night is 150 pounds per person
per nice to per night in a hotel by my
standards that's quite a nice hotel I'm
afraid and I therefore I think any
complaints that the accommodation isn't
good enough is frankly uh absolutely
indulgent and uh ungrateful
Janet Davey
you Mr Deputy speaker five separate
sources told the Sunday Times that legal
breach at Manchester needed to be
resolved urgently by rehousing Asylum
seekers in alternative accommodation are
all five lion
well as I've said I'm very happy to
confirm by reference uh uh to to the
timeline effectively you know I've been
aware of this issue for several weeks I
would love to be able to Magic up uh
thousands of beds overnight
unfortunately it's not that easy as a
result of my concerns which I uh
identified several weeks ago we've put
into place a whole operational command
to try and increase the capacity of
accommodation ease the pressure on
manston but it takes time so Christopher
Mr Devon speaker isn't the reason why
Sweden and Germany don't countenance
Asylum Seekers are from Albania the fact
that those countries don't have laws
against modern slavery which are being
abused and exploited by the Albanian
gangs
well as I said Albania is a signatory to
the European convention against
trafficking that's the originating
International Convention which
underlines our modern slavery laws there
is absolutely no reason in law why an
Albanian National cannot claim modern
slavery protection in Albania
Alex Cunningham
I don't think it was unkind of my
honorable friend the member from
wallasey to remind the Home Secretary
that the system she's rubbish time and
time again today and a product of 12
Years of touring government now staff
who had employed at manston are
extremely anxious about their
responsibilities and role and how
lawbreaking decisions affect them so can
the Home Secretary assure the house that
staff will remain free from personal
liability for any illegal decisions
taken by others including ministers
around extended detention
so great I'm very proud of this
government's track record on helping
some of the most vulnerable people
coming to this country from some of the
most dangerous parts of the world 54 55
000 visas uh issued under the Ukrainian
family scheme 138
000 Ukrainian sponsorship scheme visas
15 000 individuals from Afghanistan
under operation pitting 5 000 people
arrived in the year since operation
pitting uh 20 000 people under the
Afghan citizens resettlement scheme
that's a record of which I'm proud
you don't think Alice thank you Mr
Deputy speaker the people of
Stoke-on-Trent North kids grow and talk
are appalled by the amount of illegal
economic migrants coming across the
English Channel and again Stoke-on-Trent
which currently houses over 800 is being
asked to carry the burden with an
attempt to try and place more in the
North Stafford Hotel will my right on my
friend immediately stop this abuse of
Stoke-on-Trent and instead put illegal
economic migrants in places with open
border and free movement supporters such
as the shadow immigration minister
well was very grateful for the time that
my honorable friend gave me with his
Stoke colleagues to explain exactly the
the difficulty in Stoke and what I have
uh identified is that there is a
disproportionate distribution of
refugees throughout the country in
hotels we need to make it much more
equivalent we need to make it much more
cost effective we need to make it fair
Griffin did Mrs Deputy speaker well in
contrast to Labor's commitment to employ
a hundred extra Specialists National
Crime agency officers to tackle the
criminal gangs Upstream her predecessor
as Home Secretary asked the NCAA to draw
plans for a 40 reduction in staff so can
she now explain to us what are her plans
for NCAA stuffing and how does she
intend to improve collaboration with the
French on this problem
working collaboratively with the French
is a key component of solving this
problem we can't do it alone it's a
simple truth and that's why I'm very
pleased that we have a a relationship
with the French and I'm very keen to
amplify that relationship it will
involve greater surveillance between the
French and the British authorities it
will involve greater intelligence
cooperation upstream and interception
Upstream between the French and British
authorities it will involve joint uh
joint working at all points in the in
the system that cooperation is vital
the anichi thank you Mr Deputy speaker
I'm sure the Home Secretary knows that
she has my full support in doing it
whatever she can to be able to stop a
legal migration into this country and
we've had several conversations about
this but does she share my concerns
about placing illegal immigrants in
places that don't have the
infrastructure or the expertise to look
after people when they actually displace
it in across the UK but also would she
commit to making sure that she's talking
to colleagues on these benches when
potentially they may have
um illegal migrants coming into their
constituencies to make sure that we can
represent our constituents properly
[Music]
well ultimately we need to Bear Down on
the Asylum backlog so there are fewer
people in the UK waiting for a decision
and also we need to stop the use of
hotels at six million pounds a night
Andy McDonald thank you Mr Deputy
speaker during her first disastrous
spell in the role the Home Secretary
ignored legal advice from her officials
that explicitly set out your lawfulness
of the inhumane treatment of migrants at
the manston center that's not
inflammatory language that's fact and if
that's not bad enough she's now admitted
to Breaking the ministerial code on six
separate occasions how on Earth can she
stand at that dispatch box with a
straight face and try to defend the
cruelty towards the most desperate of
people doesn't she need to take a look
in the mirror to see who is a threat to
National Security and accept that she's
totally unfit for the job
refer The Honorable gentle into my
letter that I sent today in which I've
been very fulsome in the details of the
circumstance of the 19th of October I've
apologized for the error taken
responsibility and that's why I resigned
what I would say is that I haven't
ignored or dismissed any legal advice
that I've been provided with I can't go
into the details of that legal advice
because the law offices convention that
is part of the decision-making process
that all ministers go through we have to
take into account our legal duties not
to leave people destitute I have to take
into account the uh the the fact that I
don't want to release prematurely
hundreds of migrants into the Kent
Community I have to take into account
the value for money I have to take into
account the fairness for the British
taxpayer Richard Drax you Mr Deputy
speaker can I welcome my right or friend
to a place of thank her
for all the courageous making dealing
with a very difficult problem that the
opposition Ventures their answer is let
them all in yes that is totally totally
unacceptable can I ask my friend once
solution surely would be to return these
illegal refugees to countries from
Wednesday came if indeed it's possible
like for example Albania with how many
countries is she negotiating to do this
and how she succeeded in any of those
negotiations is that great
well you're right I mean effectively the
labor party don't have any solutions for
this problem so they'd rather spend air
time on a distraction that's what this
is all about but what I want to say to
my honorable friend is that yes we we
are having some success with returning
people more swiftly to albanians it's
early days and I don't want to overplay
it because it's still very very
difficult legally but those agreements
with those safe countries are absolutely
vital to ensure that people who are
coming from safe countries not from
persecution not fleeing War can be
legitimately returned because they are
not here for Asylum Drew Henry Mr Deputy
speaker as Home Secretary responsible
for National Security if she was made
aware of a government employee a civil
servant who despite apologies is sacked
for sharing government material several
times on private email or device which
is sanctioned that employee being
re-employed
I'm very willing to apologize for
mistakes that I have made but what I'm
not willing to do is to apologize for
things I haven't done so as I said it's
not right that there's been a breach of
National Security it's not right that
there was a document about security
matters intelligence agencies or law
enforcement those are simply not true
yeah
Mr Deputy speaker in the words of the
Home Secretary the Asylum system is
broken 12 years of touring government
and the Asylum system is broken now if
she says we've got no Solutions the Home
Secretary can press upon the prime
minister to call a general election and
let the electorate decide who they trust
more
the recent Revelations of condition for
one second please can all members now
you can see what time it is we've got
five hours of business ahead of us plus
votes questions please not statements
question please Mr Sally the recent
Revelations of conditions that manston
processing center highlight the complete
and utter failure of leadership at the
home office
will the Home Secretary do the decent
thing once again where she did it on the
19th of October and resign from that
position because of the conditions at
manston that's right
listen I'm very clear about what this
government's priority is it's about
tackling the scourge of illegal
migration taking a firm line and
changing the law where our laws are
being abused working collaboratively
with the French ensuring that we are
removing people who are not meant to be
here and ensuring that the British
people can have confidence in their
borders we Smith thank you Mr Deputy
speaker many in my constituency are
worried about paying their heating bills
many in my constituency are concerned
about getting GP appointments and many
of my hotels are full up with illegal
migrants does she appreciate the sense
of unfairness that my constituents have
and will when will legislation be coming
forward to resolve the situation
I'm so great yes I do appreciate the
seriousness of this issue and it's been
my number one priority since September
is his unacceptable that we are spending
six million pounds a day on Hotel
accommodation for Asylum Seekers it is
unacceptable that we have 35
000 Asylum seekers in hotels distributed
around the country we need to bring that
to an end we need a comprehensive plan
of alternative sites we need to speed up
our processing of Asylum we need to
remove people from the UK more quickly
and ultimately we need to change our law
and we'll be introducing legislation
later this year to ensure that there is
no longer any abuse of our laws Olivia
Blake thank you be Mr Speaker and our
refer members to my register of interest
for being a member of ramp
um I've been listening very carefully
and I would like to ask again the Home
Secretary how many extra hotel rooms has
she personally procured in her position
as Home Secretary and in her letter of
resignation she wrote pretending we
haven't made mistakes carrying on is
everyone can't see that we have made
them and hoping that things will
magically come right as not serious
politics would she agree that she has
made yet another mistake that she should
accept responsibility and that she
should resign
right I'm very pleased to repeat for the
record that since the 6th of September
under my watch over 30 new hotels have
been agreed those would provide over 4
500 additional Hotel bed spaces to be
brought into use
mark jenkinson thank you Mr Deputy
speaker
stares into his summer pledge of fixing
this crisis within a hundred days so I
hope my constituents in workington hope
that the my right number from the Home
Secretary is getting to support the chi
needs around that cabinet table yeah
absolutely what is her assessment of
those held among those held of the scale
of abuse of our modern slavery laws
I thank my honorable friend for raising
this point let me just say two points
first of all the prime minister is
absolutely committed to fixing this
problem I have absolutely no doubt
whatsoever about his determination to
fix this once and for all and I have
huge amounts of confidence in him and
I'm very grateful to him for his support
uh operationally on this when it comes
to Modern slavery laws it's not just
people coming here on the boats claiming
modern slavery uh but what they're doing
is uh that buys them effectively a year
because it takes on average 400 Days for
modern slavery claims to be processed so
they know that they will be accommodated
in the UK free of charge but it's even
worse than that we're getting uh now
serious uh foreign National offenders in
this country who have served sometimes
several years for sex offenses for drug
offenses for serious offenses and when
they finish their sentence the UK
authorities want to deport them what do
they do they claim to be a victim of
modern slavery Karen back
it's absolutely essential that the
pressures on the management center are
relieved as soon as possible it is also
essential that we do not simply
replicate some of those conditions in
the concentrations of hotels I have a
ward now where there are so many hotels
being commissioned two more this weekend
that the ratio is 800 percent above home
office guidelines the local Authority is
getting virtually no support in order to
manage this and there is no capacity at
all being provided to the Health Service
to deal with the very real health issues
that need to be dealt with will she
ensure that home office officials meet
me immediately to discuss how we ensure
that the the Asylum Seekers coming into
these hotels is properly managed and
properly dispersed well
um I'm very glad for the the minister of
State for immigration to meet uh with
the honorable lady to discuss this issue
in detail what I would say is my review
is identifying exactly the process of
identification of
um uh the hotels around the country
we're seeing a real imbalance in
geography and uh geography effectively
of of where the hotels are located
there's a real uh pressure in certain
places and then other places are not
taking uh uh people so I think we need
to bring some equivalents to this
process we ultimately need to bring it
to an end we need to make it more cost
effective But ultimately we need to be
processing people more quickly mark
alongi thank you Mr Deputy speaker we
have heard yet again today that members
opposite want to prioritize the welfare
of illegal immigrants my priority my
priority and I believe the priority of
the people on this side of the house
should be to those of our constituents
who are desperate for social housing
those constituents who are so for
certain many of them women and children
is it an outrage Home Secretary that we
are spending two and a half billion
pounds a year when we'll be soon asking
these very same people to to share the
burden of further cuts to Public
Services
an unprecedented amount of people coming
into this country many of whom are
coming illegally they require
accommodation that is putting excess
pressure on our current housing stock
whether that's hotels or the private
rented Market or other beds in other
sorts of buildings ultimately we don't
have enough space for these people and
we need to find it quickly it's very
difficult it will be done but it will
take time I'm trying to get everybody in
but you're going to have to help me so
please focus on the question rather than
a long preface Jim Shannon thank you Mr
Davis bigger again thank you
I think the the home safely for the
Endeavors uh for a truly typical complex
situation can I also ask the homicide
will they will she outline what steps
are in place to ensure that Asylum
centers are able to provide a basic
standard of mental health care for those
affected by the disgraceful action that
we can they come to home certainly
ensure that Asylum Seekers are safe
while it's waiting for the determination
of their applications as is the law in
this great nation of the United Kingdom
of Great Britain and Northern Ireland
okay great
well of course as I say and I'll I'll
reiterate it again and again I'm very
grateful for the brilliant response from
the emergency services and the
authorities and everybody at the Western
jet foil and manston yesterday and
actually uh subsequently dealing with
this incident and we are making sure
that they are well supported we we will
need more staff because of the increased
numbers I'm not going to uh you know
mislead you on that but uh we we are
trying to make arrangements to ensure
that they are supported uh so that they
are not overburdened
it's got Benton thank you
welcome the Home Secretary back to her
rightful place
she has the support of the millions of
britons who are hoping just hoping that
one day we may finally get a grip of the
small boats crisis the home Affairs
committee has been told that between one
to two percent of the entire male
population of Albania that's 10 000 men
have arrived in the UK in the past year
sure why on Earth do we accepting Asylum
claims from Albania when countries such
as Germany and Sweden do not
well we have to ensure that our Asylum
laws are fit for purpose and there has
been some great achievements uh secured
by the passage of the nationality and
borders act and they're going to be
operationalized in due course but he's
right we need to change our laws to
ensure that people are not abusing our
legal Frameworks
item thank you Mr Sexy speaker yesterday
in a horrifying attack a man threw
petrol bombs at tokhaven Immigration
Center in Dover does the Home Secretary
consider this an act of terrorism if not
why not and will she unequivocally
condemn all those who promote hatred
towards migrants
well of course I mean I'm not going to
comment on the particular details of
this case it's a very very sad case it's
a very worrying case I am very very
concerned about the safety and the
security of the the site at Western jet
for and of manston we've evacuated uh
the people from manston uh sorry from
Western and now they are back to Western
jev Wall there's been a huge amount of
effort by the authorities and I'm very
grateful to them
that anyone listening to this debate
could only conclude that the opposition
benches are more interested in illegal
economic migrants than law abiding
British people
[Applause]
well
one of the promises in the 2019 manifest
Manifesto
your friend will know was to reduce
overall numbers when it came to
migration and also to fix the problem of
illegal migration and I know my friend
that we both campaigned to leave the
European Union 17 million people voted
for control over their borders that is
what this government will deliver
of Asylum Seekers most of whom are
living in absolutely appalling
overcrowded unsafe inhumane
um circumstances and it is costing for
those in hotels above 5.6 million in
your own admission they also call for
the government to complete a summative
refugees a migration experts local
authorities housing providers to examine
options for short and long term suitable
accommodation for people seeking Asylum
will she do this
well as I've said I'm very concerned
about the
um how we accommodate people who are
waiting for their Asylum claims to be
processed we need to Bear down on that
backlog so they're not waiting for so
long and they can get a decision whether
that be to remove them or for them to to
be here on a legal basis we need to
ensure that the accommodation is cost
effective lawful and reasonable Tom Hunt
it's a deputy speaker I make no apology
for prioritizing welfare of my
constituents you said
day worrying about welfare people who've
illegally entered our country and so
scant the guards for our laws so these
reasons why I'm safe and said that the
north hotel with the Home Secretary
agree with me though but it's it is bad
we shouldn't have illegal immigrants in
in hotels But ultimately this will not
be nipped in the bud unless we get fully
behind Miranda and the definition of
refugee because we know so many people
could get who get refugees that say just
are not refugees they are economic
migrants they should be sent back
well I think modern world friend is is
right we need to call out the
misrepresentation of this problem it is
not the case that these are all refugees
fleeing persecution war-torn countries
or conflict or human rights violations
many of the people here are arriving
here on small boats are actively and
willingly procuring those Journeys they
are often paying tens of thousands of
pounds for those Journeys they are
coming here knowingly and willingly and
they are coming here for economic
reasons good green come to home for
secretary tell us how many of any
unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
have been accommodated in manston or
Western jet foil and what Arrangements
she is making to keep them in safety in
hotels properly supervised and
safeguarded
so great
well as far as I'm aware unaccompanied
Asylum seeking children are not
routinely detained at manston however
what I will say is that there were a
number of a number of unaccompanied
assigned seeking children who were
accommodated not detained for a brief
period this summer while accommodation
was being identified and of course
overnight people have been evacuated to
manston yesterday from the Western jet
fall and that will have included some
children
in Sunderland
Mr speaker thank you the issues we'll be
discussing in the house this afternoon
are symptomatic in the main of illegal
immigration
could I please first of all commend the
Home Secretary for her stated intent to
deal resolutely with the small boats
crisis and secondly can I please ask her
exactly what we might expect
for primary legislation needed and also
when
is that great well I thank my honorable
friend for his observations and
ultimately he's right there are uh we
need to be straight with people there
are there's an influx of people there's
an unprecedented number of people coming
to this country they are claiming to be
modern slaves they are claiming Asylum
uh illegitimately and they are
effectively however they are effectively
economic migrants they're not coming
here for humanitarian purposes we
therefore do need to change our laws we
need to ensure that there is a
limitation on that ability to abuse our
Asylum laws we need to ensure that our
modern slavery laws are fit for purpose
and that and cannot be exploited by
illegitimate claimants just to remind
the Home Secretary to face the
microphone because we can't I can't
quite hear everything has been said and
Hanson may have difficulties as well
Alex Sobel sidet speaker the Home
Secretary letter today outlined six
breaches where she used a personal
device to send and it's there in black
and white to send official emails using
a personal Gmail address when I receive
emails from a Gmail I assume they're
personal emails what assurances can she
give the house that none of those emails
were forwarded onto third parties and
what investigation been made that those
personal Gmail emails were not hacked by
any foreign powers
it's like Drake I have answered this
question but for repetition's sake I
will say that I have set out all the
details in the letter of the 19th of
October none of those emails were
forwarded on to anybody else I'm here to
focus on the task in hand which is a
situation at manston how we're going to
Bear Down on our Asylum backlog and I
hope I would have thought his
constituents would be more interested in
that too actually then Bradley speaker
um can I first welcome my run from the
home secretary's robust approach to this
issue which is a matter of fairness that
is hugely to my constituents
increasingly Mr Deputy speaker young men
are arriving in the UK and then later
claiming to be unaccompanied children at
that point the local Authority has to
treat them as looked after children and
then claiming to be 17 we then have to
look after them until they are 25 years
old the average cost of a looked after
child is over a hundred thousand pounds
a year I think my constituents will be
horrified to learn that their council
tax is being spent on that when it's
intended for public services so can my
right honorable friend commit to looking
at these rules and making sure that
these extortionate costs that are
hammering funds intended to support my
constituents with public services can be
changed does she agree that it'll be
impossible for the public to trust that
our immigration policies are properly
robust and fair for as long as people
can arrive here illegally from a safe
country and be able to stay here at the
expense of UK
well my honorable friend hits on a
really important aspect of the film
which is people who are coming here and
claiming to be children and we've really
seen this uh Trend over 7 several years
what I would just say about Albania is
we're getting as I said many Albanian
people come here the majority of them
are are adult single males they are not
by majority women or children or elderly
people and this claim of being a child
is something that we are going to clamp
down on and in the New Year we will be
delivering uh more robust age assessment
procedures so that there will be less
abuse of this very problem Steve McCabe
when the Home Secretary said that Indian
migrants represented the largest number
of Visa over stairs in this country was
that based on a home office briefing and
which you consider putting some details
in the library so we could all see the
extent of the problem to which he was
referring
what I'm Keen to do is ensure that we
honor our Manifesto commitment which is
to bring overall migration figures down
and clamp down on the scourge of illegal
migration I'm very keen to support uh
the government and I see my honorable
friend here who's a trade Minister uh in
in the negotiations on a historic deal
with India great friends great allies
with whom a great partnership can be
forged Brendan Clark Smith
speaker does my right honorable friend
agree with me that those who campaign to
take foreign criminals are flights those
who obstruct us from implementing our
Rwanda scheme and those who continue to
encourage the shameful behavior of
so-called Charities and activist lawyers
have done nothing but contribute to this
criminal activity and a system now
bursting at the seams
[Applause]
well my honorable friend again raises a
really important Point again what we've
seen and I speak to our heroic Board of
force officials on a regular basis and
they tell me about their first hand
experience and what they have seen is
repeated and vexatious claims they see
people arriving they're not making a
claim and then they might see a lawyer
and then they suddenly come up with a
claim after they've seen their lawyer
they make repeated and late claims as
well because they know that that's how
to game the system I think there are
real concerns about the practice of some
lawyers not all lawyers but some lawyers
and I encourage the authorities to take
action so Stevens Mr Deputy speaker so
it's a Home Secretary then acknowledging
that there are human beings at the mice
and centers who are being unlawfully
detained for long periods and if so what
assessment has our department provided
to her on the prospects of someone
issuing a legal challenge against our
department for this unlawful detention
great well I'm very clear that um you
know we have too many people
manston as of today as we have done for
some time now and that's why we're
taking urgent steps to remedy the
problem I'm about thank you Mr Deputy
speaker the home secret is absolutely
right that we need to break the model of
the business the business model the
people smokers we need to stop the boat
would she agree with me that the art the
opposition's suggestion of enhancing
safe and legal routes is a mirage
because no matter how minutes you expand
them unless you expand them to unlimited
about there will still be people willing
to take the journey so the only way we
can stop this is by making sure people
who do take that illegal route don't get
to stay in this country
secretary we have already several safe
and legal routes through which people
who are genuine Asylum Seekers can make
their application and I'm very proud as
I've set out already of our record of
welcoming people who are genuinely
fleeing persecution and War and conflict
and human rights violations however
we cannot accept the situation where
people are bypassing those routes
jumping the queue effectively on
illegitimate bases and making a
fabricated claims of being victims field
sheer Mississippi speaker the Home
Secretary blamed her predecessor for the
crisis that she's inherited twice
um and indeed the home office's own
impact assessment of the nationality and
borders Bill said it risked leading more
people to taking desperate routes to the
UK as we've seen
so why is she doubling down on the same
approach I have many constituents who've
been waiting years for Asylum decisions
what is her Target for processing claims
when will she clear the backlog and does
she agree that cost to the taxpayer
would be reduced by granting the right
to work to those whose claim to have not
been processed within six months as is
supported on both sides of the house and
overwhelmingly by the public
is that great well I I I have to
disagree with him and his
characterization what I've just said I
don't criticize my predecessor the
original member for my own friend the
member of the late um friend the member
for Witham she achieved a huge amount
during her time as Home Secretary
passing the nationality and board attack
which will take a massive step forward
in dealing with something he voted
against she secured the Rwanda agreement
a landmark partnership with our friends
in Rwanda to tackle for the first time
and head on this problem no I'm very
grateful for her work and her
contribution
Daniel Danny Krueger thank you very much
indeed Mr Deputy speaker and of course
we have moral obligations to Asylum
Seekers and it may well be the case that
conditions at manston are unacceptable
but what is totally unacceptable is the
fact that every month thousands of young
men arrive in this country from a safe
Third Country many of whom in fact set
off from a safe Third Country in the
form of Albania 40 000 in this year
alone it's half the size of the British
army I know that my right honorable
friend shares the dismay that is built
on these benches uh at this situation
unlike the benches opposite who's seen
from their questions today only
concerned to Advocate an open border
policy and to take pot shots
Minister who who had a minister who
uniquely
committed Please Mr Kruger questioned
the question is that Wilshire saw the
house that she will not be deflected
from her strategy of deterring the
illegal migration that we are seeing
what a great question for my honorable
friend thank you very much he is
absolutely right and what's more that we
are identifying with these uh with
particularly the the young single men
who are coming from Albanian is that
they are either part of organized
criminal gangs and procuring their
journey through those nefarious means or
they are coming here and take partaking
in criminal activity particularly
related to
um drugs
um our supply and otherwise in fact last
a few weeks ago I attended a raid with
the National Crime agency where we uh
where they arrested a suspected Albanian
people Smuggler in Banbury so this is a
criminal problem there are many people
coming here with Criminal Intent and
behaving in a criminal way we need to
stop it all right Shout Out Mr Deputy
speaker are the recent Conservative
Party Conference the Home Secretary
talked that was in that was her dream
indeed her Obsession to see pictures of
planes taking off her around on the
front page of the telegraph how to build
a telegraph of course does she
appreciate how offensive indeed
disturbing on the anti-humanitarian that
statement is particularly with every
bear in mind the true perspective that
there are over 80 million refugees and
attorney dispense people in the world
the UK takes proportionally less uh
refugees and many other European
countries and the home office owned
figures that from this year say that
over 70 percent of Asylum claims are
successful which by lies all this
propaganda that these are migrants
I'll tell the honorable gentleman what I
find offensive and disturbing and it's
this it's the site of thousands of
people coming to these Shores illegally
without a valid Asylum claim taking
advantage of our generosity abusing our
laws being accommodated free of charge
it's unfair it's unacceptable and it's
not right
thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker so
far this year 12 000 albanians then to
the United Kingdom through small boat
Crossing to the channel 10 000 of those
are adult single males
as Commander Dan Omani told the home
Affairs select committee the main driver
of that activity is the strength of
organized Albanian criminal gangs in the
north of France and the transfer of that
behavior to the United Kingdom together
with the determination for people to
work on the black market there is no
reason for these people to be here we
should follow the route of other
European countries and ensure that
they're returned immediately to Albania
could I therefore ask what discussions
my right honorable friend has had with
their Albanian counterpart to address
this very important issue
well I couldn't agree with my honorable
friend more he makes an exact he
identifies exactly the problem that
we're dealing with and we these are a
multi-faceted approach an agree
deploying and operationalizing our
returns agreement that we have with
Albania and ensuring that we take robust
action against uh many people who are
coming here from Albania with
illegitimate aims
thank you very much
the Home Secretary is a security risk
she says more than once in her letter to
Obama from the chair of the home Affairs
select committee the 19th of October was
the only time she used her personal
email to send home office documents to
people outside government does that
include other non-secure networks like
messaging services Does it include any
insecure communication inside government
and Does it include the times you've
spent in other departments especially
her tenure as attorney general which
lasted over a year compared with the few
chaotic weeks she's been home secretary
well I uh refer The Honorable gentleman
to my letter that I sent today that sets
out all of the details about the actions
the decisions and the rationale behind
uh the events of the 19th of October
I've apologized for the mistake I've
taken responsibility and that's why I
resigned but what this is all about is
that the honorable gentleman's party
really has no solution to the problem
that we're dealing with if labor we're
in charge they would be allowing all the
Albanian criminals to come to this
country they would be allowing all the
small boats to come to the UK they would
open our borders and totally undermine
the trust of the British people in
controlling our sovereignty
thank you Mr Deputy speaker can the Home
Secretary tell me how many places an
alternative accommodation did she
approve during the month of September
when was the first of those places
signed off when was the first person
able to be housed in that accommodation
signed off and if she doesn't have those
figures to hand would she agree to write
to me with it at the earliest
opportunity
won't
bother the chamber with repeating the
answer to that question that I've been
asked on several occasions now he will
be able to check the record for the
specific figures of the number of hotels
procured during my tenure and the number
of beds and I'm very glad that we've
taken urgent action to deal with this
issue
at one moment um I'd like to thank the
Home Secretary for her statement and
answering questions for 18 minutes short
of two hours
[Music]
before the Mrs Deputy speaker in July
the Prime Minister was recorded saying
that as Chancellor he had changed
funding formulas to benefit better off
communities at the expense of deprived
parts of the country on Sunday the right
honorable member for Surrey Heath told
Sky News this was a direct response to a
question from to someone from thanet one
of the most deprived parts of the
southeast it has since become clear that
this is not the case